[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
but uh that was nice you but the part
you're gonna really love so the gopro
hero4 blacks guess what they're called
what
that one's wesley snipes
[Music]
that one's kimbo slice
and that's james winston
he's so black dude
not skin tone just behaviorally
jameis winston i can't decide whether i
really [ __ ] love the guy like if he's
a forrest gump of football or if he is
is that the forest cup
[Music]
we're talking about stan hope you know
we're gonna call this podcast three
beards
three beers because of you what's that
they grew beards because of you cool at
least blink when you say it are you
gonna bring an intensity that kind of
kills all fun in the room because i love
that new podcast let's get to the heart
of it
oh yeah sorry thank you
uh three confederate generals sitting
here
well go ahead long street what do you
think
dave told a joke this weekend that i've
been telling everybody
yeah go ahead oh go ahead make sure i
can't tell it again do you know how much
i use
[Laughter]
fan it up to the point where we see it
in um two and a half men if it comes
back
don't fix your dials on your dials what
[ __ ] year is this i don't know you
that's right you've tuned into the right
show get ready to unsubscribe yep my
name is bobby lee and i'm ditto andrew
tito and tito andrew teacher andrew i
can call you tito tom okay oh come on
no just bert
that sounds weird no but it sounds very
like like
okay tito bert it's good to see you you
know why we do this at 4 00 p.m right
why because the the guy that normally
sits there sleeps till three
so that's when you he does the show at 4
pm this is amazing we do our show at 10
am i can't wait to do a podcast where
you only get 200 000 subscribers
[Laughter]
who [ __ ] made out on this deal i know
the [ __ ] bad friends are all of a
sudden on a red podcast yeah it's pretty
cool now the whole sudden we gotta
[ __ ] lift them up we gotta come into
this [ __ ] box and listen to this [ __ ]
dope out there this so is this should
this be like someone's like would this
is this where people shoot heroin at
this building this looks like uh this
looks like a [ __ ] storage unit it's
kind of sketchy right um i like it jesus
jesus they have beaten the [ __ ] out of
you haven't you you have do you you
you don't have to be like it's cool here
i like andrew and i like bobby you can
tell us the truth i don't like them
thank you
that's what i'm talking about uh tom
segura it's your mom's house
christina's podcast is that's
bro yeah that's deep bros rated higher
than your mom's house you know that
right
no yeah always really your mom that's
deep bro is one of the highest rated
comedy it's a great it's a great one
i've had people that don't do my podcast
yeah see how great that podcast you know
what um it's really funny we'll do the
podcast live your mom's house live yeah
and people will come up to us and i'll
be like how's it going thanks for coming
they're like
i really like that it's deep bro more
i'll be like thanks a lot
and then they'll be like we we came out
kind of hoping to see that i'm like we
didn't advertise that
like you're telling me how disappointed
you are yeah you wanted to see a
different movie like it's so we told you
to be honest when was the last time you
got 69
69 i'm gonna i'm gonna be honest i know
that it was we it's i'm gonna say
six years at least six years no it's
been it's not that long 69
yeah it's not that long no it's been a
while but not not that long the sex
position 69 yeah yeah all you asking
personal [ __ ] was what
he's [ __ ] bird because we were
talking about 69. you're doing about 69
and earlier miss giuliani how did you
hook up with these guys i'm just out of
curiosity um
attica lila
oh wait are you related yeah did you
just get a tattoo
no wait oh wait do you live with them
yeah i know who the [ __ ] you are
i know who the [ __ ] you are
who's the [ __ ] hey who the [ __ ] wonder i
just put the math together i was like
she's filipino yeah of course you are
really good at doing this man i'm
sitting here going jesus is she like a
[ __ ] kidnapped or something i know
like blink twice if you need to get let
loose i know she likes it she was like i
was i was in the philippines they
promised me some modeling work they
grabbed my passport next thing you know
i'm sitting here on the third mic on a
[ __ ] mediocre podcast looking some
[ __ ] ginger talk to a [ __ ] korean
guy to a guy who looks like an organism
be honest hold on cheers cheers to bad
friends to bad friends how
bad
is it to live with bobby oh that's right
you live with bobby
live with bobby
um how gross is he so what time yeah
like what what time does he get up to
workout
workout
can i tell you something this sounds i
don't know if this is racist or not
i never assumed the girl was white
you the girl that accused him yeah i
figured she was black why i don't know i
just never thought he'd hook up with
white chicks
like i just assumed well his girlfriend
then and now is black he has a black
girlfriend i just saw him as a guy
who would not be attracted to white
chicks
well i think they they just know that
those snow bunnies are easy to get into
because
you know that like among black guys the
whole thing is that white girls are
[ __ ] right like that's the whole thing
no yeah for sure
they're like white chicks or white
chicks will will suck it we'll put it in
their ass we'll do it like white girls
are [ __ ] so they all seriously they
all just stick their dicks in them
because they're like they'll just do it
yeah
i'm saying among college athletes for
sure
really a hundred percent well i guess
the ones that like you see the black
dudes at the mall with like those ones
that are like
fours
like then maybe sure but like like
leanne [ __ ] good luck
the white chicks i hang out with our
horse but if you go on a college campus
and like
any big d1 basketball football program
you're a black dude wait how is this
research coming from dude put it out
there and and and tell me that i'm wrong
tell me that i'm wrong
they're getting their dick sucked
by i want to [ __ ] i want to quiet i
want to call
one of my black friends really find out
oh please do
okay it's not a comic is it no no no no
but he's got he's got a comic
sensibility okay
he's uh i don't want to say who he is in
case he says something horrific here we
go yeah
all right let's call him and find out oh
i'd love i want to hear this so badly
what's his name oh you can't say i can
say i guess it's omar omar dorsey he was
in uh he's in eastbound and down okay
he's in the
uh he's the guy who i i had come over
and read the n word in my book oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah wait which word the it's
the nah never mind
he said never mind no
no he sounded like a white guy
where is he
i love that you can't believe that
someone's not answering where is he yeah
like it's awesome it's me
yeah
the only person that doesn't answer when
i call is you you have reached the
voicemail loss of eight okay
all right so uh yeah he'll call back
some well yeah we'll get some some
clarification on that oh i know another
black dude call the other black dude um
all right what's his name sterling
sterling is such a black name
you know sterling sharp
hold on hold on
sterling
[ __ ]
oh here's omar perfect timing oh great
omar
what's going on
hey uh you're on the podcast i need to
ask you i need to ask you your opinion
yeah okay uh i'm with my buddy tom and
he was saying that
that commonly known at like like say
like florida state or like a big
division one
school yeah that
that
black guy's opinions of white girls is
that they're
they're [ __ ] and easier to [ __ ] than
black chicks is that
[Laughter]
true i don't know i know they do your
homework
[Laughter]
and has anyone ever cleaned this mic
just out of curiosity
no i wouldn't imagine so that's that one
i would be more scared of than this one
oh
no [ __ ] [ __ ] my lips been touching it
i'm a little freaked out that very first
show i like my biggest goal was like
you're the first comic that i watched
where i understood i was like oh wait
what not to do say it
we used to go me and dimitri martin used
to go down at 11 35 you always did the
11 35 or 11 11 10 spot sure at the
seller and we'd go watch you every
single night and uh
and then that i worked through and i was
like i just want to tell to be like hey
great set man yeah so i go up i do my
i think he did two shows on thursday and
two shows on friday wow that was a long
time ago i can luckily if i can do one
show on thursday now and i did the same
act
thursday both shows and i i did really
well and then friday early show i do it
again and i get off stage you're like oh
are you gonna write a joke holy [ __ ] and
you're like i get it you can kill how
about telling some jokes you sure said
that
um here's the point of it
here's the point of it when you're
middling you don't have to close the
show so why not experiment but evidently
you guys don't feel that way
but that's okay
to be upset years later for being a
coward is great
name a country i'll do an accent oh this
is a fun game go ahead argentina ah
argentina there you go
really good okay okay okay
i'll say all right
hold on i'll do a full sentence hi i'm
from argentina i'm so sorry my cow got
into your yard
however let me grab my boroderos i will
catch him bring him back over to my
house i'll make a little bit of that
green stuff i like to make and put on my
meat
and then we will have some
argentinian beef all right next one
friends friends
we miss you
i'm so sorry i gave you herpes
i am smoking and i could not talk
properly as i drank my wine and came on
your teeth we we miss you very good how
about australia okay all right mate
let me get these aborigines out of here
get my kangaroo and i'll catch this
cookie and i'm gonna
throw it in the back of my
big truck
you're nailing it keep going germany
[Laughter]
ah
and i'm from germany
i like to be tied up and [ __ ] on
that is my thing
cause i'm from germany
kind of fading off there but yeah good
first first three greenland greenland
hello
i am from greenland
very nice to have you in my country a
lot of people assume that iceland has
green stuff and green and red stuff but
it's not that way
i'm from greenland would you like a
piece of whale
keep going russia
hello i am russian are you the machine
you are okay i think did my accent
follow your part back to france
i think i'm going back to france
nailing it nailed it
korea korea i'm not gonna do that one
do it in honor of that no no no no no no
no no hi i'm bobby bobby lee i take my
shirt off i have a small dick all right
tom's probably the
uh
the brand for that because i think
all of his fans discovered him on
netflix see that's great a lot yeah
that's great and then through that
discovered him on his podcast and i
think rogan rogan's outreach i think his
podcast has been really big he's really
like his reach is so wide that we get
like you know
uh whatever trickle-down effect from
from joe yeah well joe joe is unique all
the way around both on and off stage and
like uh you know what he does on his
podcast is pretty intense and amazing
and the way he does connect because when
i meet somebody who says hey i heard you
on joe's podcast it's like i know that
person is a comedy fan yeah they know a
lot about comedy that's right
there you go did i remember you know you
were my i was my first feature week ever
at brea
the proving grounds as they call it the
uh the tough love i did a second week
with him like a year later yeah and i
and i did one joke
from the year before and he goes what do
you want to be an actor or something and
i was like what and he goes
it's it's it's it's been a year you
can't write 20 new minutes i was like oh
geez yeah that was after a lot of
drunken battling but i mean i like you
half have told this story like a chick
but um
no i know now you slam bray hardcore in
fact um
you get top bids at the stoned uh stone
ice cream parlor across the street
that's the saddest part of that club
when you're like i didn't sell out but i
look across the street and there's a
line around the block for ice cream
because comedy will never beat ice cream
hey man this is a [ __ ] show
what's so rude what's the problem
everything's a problem the [ __ ]
the chairs goddamn rudy your staff
you know i come in here dude i come in
here dude right speak english speak
english go ahead
oh that's very funny i come here right
and i say hi to the the
the larger guy that works here which i
can do whatever the guy bird
yeah the circle right and then i come in
here and i say hey the bad right
the guy other guy the jew
right
so nice even though i was 20 minutes
late so nice right 30 minutes late right
what are you doing over there that woman
that in there her name is jules she's
she's my daughter pretty much they're
trying to steal her food
that's crazy hey guess what what bert
took one of her own crustables
oh
[ __ ] let me talk to jules okay
bobby
how are they they're really kind of talk
like a white person
[Laughter]
get out of there hi
hi bobby
hey bobby everything is good everything
is good
hey i gotta tell you something hung up
on him
[Applause]
oh that was fun oh dino bobby what are
we just talking about guys with guns jd
so we going to jd's is the jameson
comedy tour and all right it's me steve
byrne
uh danny bevins and billy gardell
and and the second we roll in i'm
closing the show because i'm the loudest
of the group and so uh
jd says i don't know that guy he's not
closing billy gardels closing and billy
is the guy for you guys that don't know
is a guy on billy gardell's own michael
molly he's mike
not molly
and so uh and so so he's like he's like
yeah don't don't worry uh berto berto
close the show he says no i don't know
who bernie is you're closing the show he
[ __ ] hated my gus until the very end
of the night last week i someone said he
was in the outlaw biker game right jd's
had a stroke i think yeah he died oh
he's not he's in bad shape he's in bad
shape yeah he's a good guy i like to so
we go out to the thing and i said so jd
you're an outlaw huh which you don't say
to a biker and he goes excuse me i said
you're the biker gang outlaw like i'm
being such a [ __ ] guy in a movie yeah
you're in the biker gang the outlaws
he's the square guy and he was like uh
what do you know about the outlaws i
said my dad represented them in florida
i said slowpoke and lefty and jd goes
you're out chrysler's kid what i swear
to you i swear to you and he goes are
you [ __ ] kidding me god damn it we
come in the office you'd be that little
kid that's you i said yeah in tampa
there's a bunch of guys that bring out
arrested in jacksonville on this big
case my dad represented them and my dad
would talk about the [ __ ] biker gang
and i remember the names
unsavory [ __ ] about these guys
and this guy went are you [ __ ] he
started bringing [ __ ] over i
remember it was snowing because he had
an escalade do you remember that and it
was always clean as [ __ ] and he was like
come on over come on over he goes this
is uh he's his dad was a lawyer for the
[ __ ] outlaws and i remember i
remembered and then also next week i got
an offer to do a weekend there 1300. it
was 1300 for like [ __ ] seven shows
and you had to stay at that condo i know
we said hotel i didn't go back i didn't
go back oh my gosh i made a bet with the
the bar staff that on sunday i'd make
500 for tips and everyone i promised
them and i said if if i'm wrong you guys
all have to get naked on stage but if
i'm right i'll get naked on stage and
you can take a picture with me and i was
wrong
uh they didn't make 100 and yeah jd goes
take your [ __ ] clothes off and i was
like i was like a joke bat jd i was
trying to raise their tips and he was
like take your [ __ ] clothes off so
there's a picture of me naked on stage
with everyone from uh joker hey did you
like american my recommendation in and
of itself
on hulu
could not sit through it why not what
was the point of it
that's an interesting question um what
what do you think the point of it was uh
i i'm sure i had to be happy to have a
really great secret ending where he was
related secret ending
or something had to have something
because i i was i mean i don't mean to
[ __ ] on it i'm sure that guy is
extremely talented he is he is he's a
but here's the other thing is like i did
a podcast with him i know i saw that and
then i was like and you're like i don't
want to give away your show and so i was
like okay it's going to be a good show i
started watching with leanne and leanne
sajak do you guys have the word [ __ ] in
philippines um what is it we can say
or puttangina
and that's the [ __ ] specs did that
they came there and they can say that
he's spanish um the uh i hope you don't
think i'm apologizing for [ __ ]
and i'm his friend i can say it too
leanne just goes i don't get it like
five minutes in five minutes in yeah so
now i'm like she's because it takes a
little longer because he's like this is
the crosstalk yeah whatever yeah and so
and leanne's like i don't get it where
is this going where is this going and
i'm like hey can you stop please because
i'm trying to enjoy it and she's like
okay yeah that's how to ruin it yeah and
then she's like it's slow and i was like
babe it's not slow it's just he's
building to something yeah and then i'm
rooting for him i'm like please do
something [ __ ] big oh yeah and then
45 minutes in 47 minutes in he still
kind of done anything big and i'm like i
mean if he brings it was interesting
when he's like all right can the person
who's here at the last show stand up and
that person stands up you'll be here
tomorrow you don't know what's going on
they don't know what's going on yeah
it's like building to something i'll
watch the second half it was just at 47
minutes i was sober and i was like it
needs to speed up okay like
there's not a lot of action and then i'm
like i'm definitely not watching set up
set of settle yeah yeah yeah well uh no
because i'm like i don't can't trust
your [ __ ]
your your recommendations you could see
the feedback on my recommendations no
yes have you guys seen uh in and of
itself yeah fancy did you like it i
loved it
how the [ __ ] bro listen to me okay
you
saying that you didn't get it and tapped
out is an endorsement of the show
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]